[Aplausos]
estamos prontos para o court
o investimento de um filho com certeza
não é o poder vivenciar em uma vida com
ela um direito quase garantido mas para
muitos este de hidrato é muito difícil
de cumprir
em filadélfia diz quase 15% da população
milhões de pessoas em todo o mundo
provavelmente não passaram por isso
alguns dos vossos amigos ou familiares
está a passar por esse problema mas
sabiam que quatro em dez pessoas que
procuram ajuda médica
eu digo tem uma infecção respiratória e
vai ao médico tratar porque com o seu
problema não procura ajuda
temos que acabar com o estigma temos que
acabar com o infortúnio temos que acabar
com o destino com a segmentação
infertilidade é uma doença uma doença
caracterizada pela organização mundial
de saúde há muitos muitos anos mas que
infelizmente ainda não entre pintada
como tal o que nós temos para oferecer
vamos procurar factores masculinos
femininos sabendo que em 30% dos casos
será a junção dos factores masculinos e
femininos que estarão a causar essa
dificuldade em engravidar mas também a
10% dos casos em que não se chegou a
nenhuma conclusão chamar a infidelidade
de opá tica mas é muito importante
também acabaram de com a culpabilização
não não é a mulher culpada da
infertilidade não é um homem é que não
há culpados aqui estou há factos que às
vezes por caminhos que sejam todos
juntos acabam por criar esse problema
que para tantos nem sequer se coloca o
tal direito adquirido
então depois desse estudo
vamos oferecer algum tratamento às vezes
são tratamentos tão simples como induzir
uma avançando uma mulher que não faz
ovações todos os meses
outras vezes uma cirurgia resolve um
problema de uma mulher que já estava a
tentar engravidar há dez anos sempre
teve dores com as instruções e é mais
dizia filhas é normal porque eu também
já tive tua avó já teve
portanto é seita e ela tem que tomar
comprimidos para poder de trabalhar
já faltou à escola por causa disso e
alguém vítimas que não procura ajuda
médica e vai ao médico e descobre que
afinal aquelas dores é que eu é aquela
qualidade de vida alterada todos os
meses
chamas endometriose endometriose é uma
doença que leva nova anos a ser
diagnosticada está descrita em todos os
papas internacionais
já imaginaram o que nova anos consulta
após consulta até que alguém se lembra
que esta doença existe
além disso esta doença está em 40%
associada à infertilidade
portanto nós descobrirmos também estamos
a dar mais uma mais-valia essa pessoa é
vencer não essa doença tem tratamento
muitas vezes fazemos uma cirurgia
tratamos aqui o quisto está no alvário
desobstruímos as trompas e passados dez
anos a tentar 10 anos foi condutor é que
o casal tem um filho que tanto esperava
há tanto tempo mas também quando o
tratamento meio de tratamento cirúrgico
não dão essa resposta eficaz temos
outros tratamentos possíveis é tal pm a
procriação medicamente assistida o que
que é isso que vamos fazer se um cadinho
vamos voltar atrás no tempo
wisdom nasceu em 1978
quase no mesmo ano em que eu mexi por
isso também é interessante ter entrado
nesta área porque é uma área com a qual
vou preenchendo todos os dias e nesses
40 anos de evolução
muita coisa já conseguimos muita coisa
assim e já conseguiu dar resposta
tivemos a fertilização in vitro depois
verificamos que alguns daqueles
o episódio não conseguiu fundar o ovo
falha de condenação o então companheiro
na poc e descobrimos que muitos eram
imóveis ou anormais
então conseguir passar para outro tipo
de tratamento é chamada icce
o que quer dizer que conseguimos injetar
diretamente os produtos oi dentro do ovo
para permitir que haja uma fundação para
permitir que haja uma possibilidade de
gravidez depois também concurso que
estão nas instâncias crianças com
doenças genéticas cromossômicas só
conseguimos fazer algo por essas pessoas
se ia por seu o diagnóstico genético pré
implantatório com a possibilidade para
tirarmos uma célula do embrião de oito
células ou blastocisto o quinto dia
consegui estudar aquela célula e
perceber se esse embrião é um embrião
afetado com a mesma doença do pai ou da
mãe ou ampliam saudável permitindo dessa
forma se transfira para dentro do outro
o embrião que já não vai ter a doença
dos pais
imaginem a felicidade que é uma pessoa
que sempre dificultar com uma doença
difícil e ter a certeza que o filho vai
a caminho
já não vai passar pelo mesmo outras
técnicas também surgiram
importantíssimas foi criada a
preservação gum tas precoce esperança
que trouxe imagina em cada vez mais nós
chamamos assolados por doenças
oncológicas em idades cada vez mais
jovens e podemos dar esperança aquela
pessoa que depois da sua luta pela
doença oncológica terá no final daquele
percurso aquela luz ao fundo do túnel e
luz ao fundo do túnel e poder depois
engravidar ter um filho pra muito vencer
subsídios e doenças do que me é é
tratamento de quimioterapia e seus
próprios tratamentos são tóxicos para os
ovários tóxicos para os ticos e por
tantos não permitiam ter essa esperança
e agora com as novas técnicas criam
preservação
tudo isso é possível também uma dúvida
que restava era será
as crianças nascidas de fertilização in
vitro outras técnicas vão poder criar
espontaneamente e aqui está o luís
branco o seu filho uma gravidez
espontânea
portanto sim é possível também 2014 um
dos grandes avanços ea possibilidade do
transplante outro
a mulher que me achem sem outro e
portanto vai trazer também uma nova luz
nestes 40 anos a ciência evoluiu imenso
das respostas aos mais variados destinos
problemas mas temos que ter em atenção o
seguinte nós apesar de tentarmos
otimizar é que o que há três anos da
demanda dos ovários a produzir vários
flui com os vários ovos não conseguimos
ultrapassar é taxa de contabilidade
natural do ser humano e às vezes em
consultas chegamos muitas mulheres que
dizem eu não sabia disso pensa que
ciências ouvia tudo por esse programa ea
minha vida tirei o curso de cayma
empresa e agora sim agora que era o
momento certo para engravidar
o tempo vai passando ea frustração vai
aumentando de forma exponencial
portanto não conseguimos programar tudo
ea ciência não consegue dar essa
resposta em pleno e porque imaginem o
seguinte imagina uma mulher que tem
dentro do filtro outra mulher
será mera uma menina é semi netra 7
milhões de ovócitos na barriga de sua
mãe mas ao mexer por morte celular
programada e só voz its vão diminuir 7
milhões para 2 milhões e na puberdade
esses dois milhões já são só 400 mil e
pode quer da menstruação mês após mês
vamos gastando esta é nossa reserva
owari que quer até que acabemos com mil
e entramos e menopausa e é isso que ela
não sabe ela não sabia que reservar e
que ia diminuindo com a idade
pensava que era por volta dos 50 anos
quando entrava na menopausa não sabia
que aos 35 anos apesar de estarmos no
auge da nossa
ferreira os nossos vovôs city já estão
com grande falha e aos 38 ainda mais
nós faremos os seguintes no homem é cada
72 dias produz mais de 15 milhões de
espermatozóides uma grande diferença não
acham
pois é portanto é muito importante
passar essa ideia do impacto de idades
das taxas sexto tratamento e então
resolvi fazer um estudo tem com a nossa
população que vem contra outros dados
internacionais que se a será que a
população em geral têm noção do impacto
da fidelidade será que a população em
geral têm noção da taxa de contabilidade
natural do ser humano
então perguntávamos quanto é que acha
qual é a percentagem se o casal tiver
relações no pedido feito por mês
qual é a percentagem possível gravidez
então mais 30 por cento respondeu ah com
certeza mais 50% com armas no estado
engravida e ou 25 por cento respondeu a
mais de 90% horas tem gravidade é tão
fácil mas qual é a realidade
o ponto fulcral é que taxa de quando
abordado humana é de 25 por cento a 25
por cento por mês
mas reparem 25% por mês
aos 22 anos porque estivemos a falar 38
anos já estamos a falar de 12 6 por
cento 50 por cento dessa taxa que já é
baixa e não estamos só a falar de
quantidades
temos que falar também de qualidade da
voz solitária ea qualidade também vai
diminuindo à medida que a nossa reserva
diminui a qualidade dos próprios avós e
também diminui
é importante termos o vosso esmalte
vamos ter embriões maus temos sempre os
maus não ter mais taxa do apartamento
parei que como aumentar exponencialmente
a partir dos 38 anos a taxa do
apartamento
cantarolando articulado que conseguimos
uma greve vez
mesmo tendo essa sorte arriscamos em que
a partir de determinada idade extras
transforma num aborto e que a gravidez
não evolua preciso que as taxas de
sucesso dos tratamentos de procriação
medicamente assistida que andam à volta
de 30 e 35 por cento
quando estamos a falar de pessoas com 42
anos as taxas baixas para 5% de gravidez
1 e 2 por cento ascendendo assim de fito
que é isso que nós pretendemos
então essas minhas doentes seis meses
dizem 'não eu realmente não tinha
conhecimento disso não sabia que a
ciência não dava resposta ao meu faktor
biológica
sim porque a sociedade em curtas que
temos em tempo não é que temos com
dedicado à carreira que vemos atriz do
xi do cinema é terem filhos aos 47 48
anos muitas vezes fruto tratamente com
doação de ovos do vosso se portanto a
sociedade indígenas que temos sempre
tempo mas não é real e também estamos
fruto de uma influência ambiental
reparei que nos seguintes foi um estudo
organizado pela organização mundial de
saúde em que foram estudar 4.500 homens
que foram pais há pouco tempo em que o
ator fez do país do mundo inteiro o que
qualificaram verificaram que os
critérios que antes eram considerados
normais dos parâmetros promat custos
estavam muito diminuídas
é concentração tenha diminuído ao longo
do tempo é mobilidade amor fugia tão
diminuídas que entenderam que era
preferível mudar os critérios
normalidade porque realmente queira
normal há uns anos atrás já não é que
nós somos fruto também do todo este meio
ambiente se ao do tabaco dos 23 da
alimentação do contato com produtos
químicos pesticidas etc portanto também
temos que contar
com isso não só com o nosso facto
biológica e também é importante que
tenham ambição do impacto que isto tem
não só a nível individual mas da
sociedade a um estudo interessante
construiu que as pessoas que passam por
estes problemas vivenciam ansiedade que
gostam e 13 quase tão próximo como uma
pessoa que passa por uma doença
oncológica que porque é muito difícil
nós aceitar uns que não temos tudo à
nossa disposição é muito difícil nesta
sociedade do século 21 percebemos que
afinal não tínhamos toda a informação
necessária para tomarmos decisões na
altura certa e por isso quando
perguntaram por que é que os que nesta
área
apesar da visão holística que pode
tratar um casal fazer com que um de que
os desejos estão garantidos não é pra
quase todos que não é esse então tão
garantido apesar de o ter cá poder fazer
mais do ponto de vista clínico poder
fazer investigação à procura de fato
todo mundo é claro e químicos que
aumentem o sucesso destas técnicas o meu
então era isso e cheguei à conclusão que
era muito importante passar essa
informação passar a informação do do
poder de termos conhecimento que a idade
é muito importante no sucesso para uma
grave vez o conhecimento permitem
escolher a brigar